tunis dans le viseur de l'organisation
des nations unies et du haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés est
devenu le point de passage obligatoire
pour rejoindre l'europe la tunisie fait
face depuis quelques années à un flux
important de migrants africains qui
transitent par la libye dépassés par la
situation et dépourvu de cadre juridique
tunis n'a cessé ces derniers mois de
procéder à des expulsions parfois
violentes de ces migrants vers la libye
si dans un communiqué cette rapporteur
de l'onu ont tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
sur les conditions de détention de ces
populations qui sont très souvent privés
d'eau de nourriture de soins médicaux
est exposé un réel danger de tortures
d'enlèvements et de violences sexuelles
écoutez nous sommes profondément
préoccupés par la sécurité la dignité
l'intégrité physique et les conditions
de vie des migrants en particulier des
femmes enceintes et des enfants qui sont
bloqués à la frontière tuniso libyenne
ces personnes sont soumises à des
violations de leurs droits en tunisie et
en libye à la lumière des rapports que
nous avons reçus sur l'augmentation du
traitement raciste et xénophobe des
migrants d'afrique subsaharienne à tunis
la société civile s'organise pour venir
en aide à ces déplacés de plus en plus
nombreux à s'installer dans le pays en
attendant de rejoindre de façon
clandestine les côtes italiennes elle
dénonce une précarisation des conditions
d'accueil de ces réfugiés et violation
flagrante de leurs droits les plus
élémentaires pour honda et ben amor
membres du forum économique et social
tunisien la tunisie doit se doter
rapidement d'une politique migratoire
éclaircie à ses relations avec l'union
européenne écouter le natif
il ya une vraie absence de stratégie
nationale en matière d'immigration et
une absence totale de position notamment
en matière de soumission aux politiques
européennes et au chantage qui exercent
l'union européenne en vue d'intensifier
les contrôles côté méditerranée de ce
fait la tunisie est devenue une
plateforme de filtrage des migrants sans
cadre juridique qui protège leurs droits
et sans moyens humains logistiques et
matériels pour préserver leur dignité je
pense que les organisations de la
société civile font un effort
considérable pour surveiller et
documenter les violations dont les
migrants sont victimes malheureusement
nos moyens financiers logistiques
demeurent très faibles et cette
situation dépasse les capacités des
organisations internationales et celle
de la société civile pour gérer au mieux
cette catastrophe humanitaire
bien que signataire de la convention de
genève relative aux réfugiés tunis ne
s'est toujours pas doté d'un cadre
juridique indispensable à son
application en 2021 sur les 6500
demandeurs d'asile que compte le pays
moins de trois mines ont pu obtenir le
statut de réfugié